why is nuclear energy not like the
saving grace of our civilization we like
sort of gave up
and I don't understand why and I want to
understand why this is a great story yes
I've looked into this in some ways for
various videos
um but I've never gone straight at it
I've never done the like what the heck
happened with nuclear video I feel like
I will have a clearer version of the
story if we can do it sort of tag team
are we gonna do the cynic Optimist thing
I maybe yes here's the plan I'm going to
go down the rabbit hole on why people
are afraid of nuclear energy like what
is the actual deal here what are the
events and the things that freak us all
out and I'm gonna figure out okay so
what do we do about that how do we use
rare in the future and we can compare
notes to look at like is there a future
for this technology and should we
actually be as afraid as we are awesome
all right